Speaker 1: I don't even totally understand this
story fully yet. It appears as though George
Anthony Devil. There's Santos lying Republican
congressman. Brokered the sale of a $19 million
yacht. What? I know. It just. It doesn't make
any sense, but this is now the latest bizarre
thing involving the sky. The New York Times
reports that just before his House election,
Santos helped two of his largest donors reach
a private deal on a $19 million luxury yacht.
This has captured the attention of federal and
state authorities that are investigating Santos.
The sale was not previously reported, is one of
about a dozen different leads being pursued by
the FBI, the U.S. Attorney's office in Brooklyn
and the Nassau County District Attorney's Office.
Prosecutors and FBI agents have sought in recent
weeks to question the new new owner of the 141
foot Superyacht. Raymond Santillo, a Long Island
auto dealer, about the boat and his dealings
with Santos and his fundraising efforts. Tan Tello
bought the boat from Myra Ruiz, a Republican donor
in Miami. Santos negotiated the payment. What
the hell is going on? The payment was 12 and a
quarter million upfront and six and a half million
more in installments and advised the two of the
logistics of turning over the yacht. This took
place just a few weeks before the election. What?
It's not clear what laws, if any, were broken.
Several election law experts say that if the
sale was designed to inject money into Santos's
campaign, it may violate federal law governing
caps on campaign contributions. It would also
could be illegal if Santos tied any commission
he received on the sale to previous or future
donations, even if no laws were broken. It is
more evidence of an emerging narrative of people
in his orbit that Santos used his campaign not
only to win, but also as a networking exercise to
ingratiate himself with rich donors and to enrich
himself himself through a lawyer representing him
in potential criminal matters. Santos has denied,
declined to comment, but denied wrongdoing. This
is crazy. And of course, the biggest story is
this paragraph right here. A central mystery like
there's a bigger story here about the money. With
Santos, a central mystery writes The New York
Times is Santos's sudden unexplained jump in
income and where he got the money to loan him loan
himself about $700,000 for the 2022 campaign. In
2020, he reported an income of 55,000. Two years
later, he reported a salary of three quarters of
a million and over a million in dividends from his
company, The Florida based developer organization
Disanto Santo to Santos. Santos described it
as a capital introduction into the business.
This is. This is really crazy. Oh, one other
element here. Santos said publicly that his
company brokered deals between high net worth
clients and an interview with Semaphore in
December. He explained his work, saying
if a client wants to sell a plane or boat,
he puts a feeler out there, adding that he's
landed some million dollar contracts. If you're
looking at a $20 million yacht, my referral
fee, there can be anywhere between 200 and
$400,000. It turns out that he did deal in a
yacht worth almost $20 million. This is just
a really sketchy guy, a compulsive liar drawn to
behavior that is at minimum on the edges of legal.
And we'll find out potentially actually against
the law. I told you weeks ago, we are not at the
end of the Jorge Santos stories and clearly we
are not at the end of the Jorge Santos stories